Contrary to what many people think, military bases and embassies do not count as American territory.
Yet it comes close.
The host country agrees that its laws do not apply in that area but the bases are still in its area.
That is hers.
Because it's hers.
In her country.
This is called extraterritoriality, and it is not unique to America, but America stands out for its large number of bases and embassies,
and in one case (Guantanamo Bay, Cuba) for his fight over the bases.
The short version of the story is this:
Cuba used to belong to the United States,
(Captured after the Spanish-American war with Puerto Rico, and Guam, and pride of Spain).
After the decolonization of Cuba, the navy remained the base of the United States,
where it was and the United States paid for the rent of the land.
And then revolucion and disagreement between Cuba and the United States about the rent,
which led to the current uncomfortable situation:
where the United States says to Cuba: "Thanks for renting this country out to us!"
and Cuba that says: "We have not rented this country out to you."
and the United States that says, "Here's the rent!"
and Cuba that says, "We don't accept that, would you please leave?"
and the United States that says, "Thanks for renting the land to us!"